“You should know what I want without me having to ask”
probably said it or you've probably had it told to you
But that kind of falls under the Assumption
that your partner is a mind reader
As far as I know
no one can do or no one is a mind reader
They just can't, that's just not how humans work
maybe with advanced technology and AI one day that could be a possibility
but as of right now
it's not possible
if you want your partner to do a specific thing for you
You have to lay it out for them
you have to explain to them and communicate
that's why if you want your partner to do something
you have to ask for it
not only is it okay to ask
you have to ask more than half the time because we are not AI
they can't read your mind
The way everyone learns is through communication
saying hey
I'd really like if you took out the garbage before it got overfilled
hey, I'd like if you cooked my favorite meal for me every once in a while to surprise me
or hey
spending one on one time together is really important to me
I'd like if we did more of that
whatever it is
you have to be willing to lay it out for them
You have to be willing to open up and express your desires directly
Then you can actually often get to a place where it's like yeah
I know what you want and you know without me explaining
but it doesn't start there
anybody who is there
probably started with a ton of communicate about what they need from each other
it's as simple as that
communication